A deer told himself every day,...
..."I am the most handsome deer in the forest."
"My large chest is a symbol of my power...
...and my beautiful horns impress other animals."
But he did not like his legs and hooves.
"My legs are narrow and my hooves are ugly."
"They do not satisfy me."
One day, the deer saw a big dog.
The deer made some noise and disturbed the dog.
The dog woke up and chased him.
The deer felt terror.
He screamed.
He did not want to be a victim, so he ran into the forest.
His strong legs helped him run fast.
His pale brown hooves were hard,...
...so they were not sensitive to rough rocks.
However, his horns got caught in branches, slowing him down.
His large chest could not fit between thick trees.
The deer estimated that he ran for an hour.
He felt like he was running a marathon.
In the end, the deer escaped the threat of the dog.
He sat in the shade of a tree.
"That was almost a disaster!"
"I almost did not escape because of my chest and horns."
"My legs and hooves saved me."
As a consequence, the deer learned to honor his fast legs...
...and have confidence in his strong hooves.
"Pretty things only supplement important things.", he thought.